Do you have any suggestions for brain cancer, supplements, etc.?
Well, brain cancer is unique, so let's jump back to diet a little bit.
So, when I said that every cancer can be different as far as diet goes, there are some generalities to follow.
Now, typically, a colon cancer, colorectal liver, pancreatic cancer typically are going to be fed.
Again, this is a gross generality, but typically the source of fuel is going to be more apt to be amino acids' proteins.
So, those of the cancers, the GI type cancers, are more apt to be fed through proteins' amino acids,
so they would probably be better with GI type cancers to go on a cut out animal proteins, go more vegetarian-like as far as your diet goes.
That would be your best guess if you were going to take a guess at it.
Brain cancers are a different ball of wax, so it depends on the type of brain cancer.
So, astrocytomas, those that's a cancer that originates in astrocytes, tend to be fed through glutamine and create glutamine as their own fuel source.
That's kind of a negative of astrocytomas. Now, glutamine is an amino acid, so we never suggest any of our cancer patients to be taking glutamine.
Even if their cancer is glycolidicly driven completely, meaning through glucose completely,
glutamine would be a supplement that a lot of people would be taken to heal their gut, elglutamine.
Oh, I have leaky gut, so my doctor would be an elglutamine.
We take all of our patients off an elglutamine. We don't want any of our cancer patients on elglutamine.
So, an astrocytoma brain cancer, it would be probably wise to limit unbeatable acids,
thereby limiting animal proteins, thereby cutting down an elglutamine.
It also goes for glutamates, so glutamates is a food additive that is added to food as a flavor enhancer,
and glutamate converts to glutamine through a specific genetic pathway that we look at in your genes.
And with this specific defect on this certain gene pathway, you could to glutamine right quite rapidly and back to glutamate.
So, with astrocytomas, long story short, good idea of kind of animal proteins.
Other brain cancers tend to be fed through glutolosis, tend to really love sugar.
Again, this is a gross generality, but it's more often than not, brain cancers do better with a ketogenic diet.
If it's an astrocytoma, you could go on a ketogenic diet with decreasing animal proteins, so it's going to be a much more vegetable and high fat diet.
So, most brain cancers, again, do better on a ketogenic diet, and again, it doesn't have to be complete ketosis,
getting it into complete ketosis and staying in complete ketosis, because it's very difficult to do.
And it's difficult to mutter, and just a ketone stick your test doesn't truly show up a person as in ketosis or not,
just because you're really ketones.
So, but if you get into a ketogenic like diet, you really reduce the glucose,
so you can count your grams of glucose, getting it down below 15 grams of glucose per day,
really for brain cancer patients would be very appropriate and very high fat vegetable type diet.